[Music]
all right this one's gonna be pretty
interesting are you ready there's a man
from bart can you pronounce
hi long jang province china i have to
see how it's spelled uh h-e-i-l-o-n-g-g
hi long jiang maybe oh sick that's good
and kind of funny
so he buys
he buys three jars of snake wine
believing that the drink could help cure
his son who has been suffering from a
chronic illness
so he then he he opens the jars
and he left them untouched for a year so
they could have enough medicinal
properties he believed that if you left
them alone that
the liquids with the
the snakes inside of it and all kinds of
[ __ ] going on he opened it and then left
it there he's like fermenting it so then
after a year long of marination the man
claims he decided to finally
um
take the bot take the so he he unsealed
him but then he decided to take the the
cork off of him right
uh and administer the traditional
chinese medicine only to find that all
three of the venomous steaks came back
to life before one of them bit him
how's that even whoa
were they hibernating all three of them
they were hibernating so that medicine
does work though
on the snakes yeah it works on the snake
that means that they stuck a live snake
in that [ __ ] jaw which they usually
do do that oh really i didn't know yeah
but
if you're gonna
it's gonna drown like that's like a bee
in the freezer huh like you put in the
freezer and they take them out three
months later and go
you put bees in the freezer i don't know
i've heard people experimenting all
right people put bees in the freezer and
they kind of chill out for a little bit
and then you take them out then they can
yeah i could understand this on some
like cockroach [ __ ] or some other stuff
like that but like when you put like a
snake into wine you put b in the freezer
bar what the [ __ ] going on i didn't do
it
it's a jk news article
i think it was flies or something it's
hot tea we brought right now
for the snake right doesn't have to
[ __ ] breathe
that's a whole year of being an alcohol
or is it like a hibernating ass like
thing like you know like makes your
[ __ ] weird dude oh yeah
that's why they're like devil's creature
they can hibernate but that's the devil
the [ __ ] devil or cold-blooded right
so they may be like their heart rate
slows down to one beat a week or so
that's probably exactly what it is
traditional chinese medicine
practitioners believe that snake wine
contains several health benefits and can
be a cure for rheumatism arthritis and
the flu the drink is often prepared by
fitting a snake inside a jar of alcohol
which is what happened here usually it's
rice wine and leaving it there to
marinate for months a cure some experts
say that what happened to the father is
not entirely strange and snakes can
supposedly live inside of a jar of
alcohol for 12 months without dying
especially if the lid is slightly open
for the air to enter wow
how come it didn't just slide out uh bro
it was still it was still closed right
it was just
it wasn't completely sealed it wasn't
air tight yeah exactly so so it didn't
suffocate so according to a a
herpetologist and don't ask me what that
is i don't [ __ ] know he yeah he knows
what herpes is apparently
he says that what happened is
biologically impossible no sick no snake
can ever survive
submerged in any kind of liquid in a
bottle for more than an hour so maximum
but obviously he doesn't believe in
eastern medicine anyway so [ __ ] but do
you think he was trying to
bust a con and then he's like oh your
snakes bit me now i need oh yeah is
there any kind of after a year
that's an interesting con but it
happened too like it actually happened
he actually has a snake bite like snake
did he get bit by all three of them
he's like well at least i could try this
one i'll goddamn or at least i could try
this one oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what if you just got another snake
had that one bite you
and then you go hey you're snakes man
that [ __ ] was a lot and just dip it in
the wine once for the essence they match
the fang shape to them i know right
they id the snake you guys seen this
stuff in like [ __ ] asian stores where
they sell ginseng and [ __ ] like that
where they got those giant like
alcoholic bottles and there's like uh
it's like bugs centipedes snakes i've
seen those yeah there's like other
random shitty snakes that's why i got a
north korean liquor that has deer antler
in it
whoa you had me at north korean
let's make sure
korean i was in um i believe it was
spain yeah i was spain i was in espana
and they i was at a bar that also had
this type of alcohol that had like a
type of bug at the bottom i don't
remember what it was it was like a
wormish type of uh
probably at the bottom of tequila as
well yes and then um i had learned
and this was like after uh two spanish
teams were just playing football
soccer for us
uh and people were celebrating there so
everybody started like pouring drinks
and stuff and then when they got to uh
my drink
it was the last a bit of alcohol in that
bottle and then they said that the
tradition is if you are the person who
gets the last amount of alcohol in the
bottle you also have to consume the bug
you got to eat the worm man how big is
the worm it was it wasn't huge but i was
just saying i had to swallow it it was
crazy did you chew it or you just it
looks like a little grub right it does
look like a grub why did they do that i
don't know who came up with the idea
maybe it's a joke and then joke's on me
i don't know i got a bug in me took this
[ __ ] out man would you even open this
[ __ ] i wouldn't
be like
no that's a big ass jar that's a cobra
doesn't look like a pokemon that's an
example it's not necessarily just
straight a wreck like that
that's crazy man that looks like those
[ __ ] science
room things where they [ __ ] save the
animals and [ __ ] the jars catholic come
out in a year and bite you have you guys
drank one of these i'd rather just have
the flu not the snake one i'm gucci dude
i don't need it i don't need the [ __ ] in
my life
there's scorpion ones too what about the
tiger dick i've never seen the tiger
dick one but everyone says he's never
even heard of the titans
[ __ ]
i just bought this laptop no there's a
tiger dick tiger dick tiger penis
don't tell me somebody's going around
cutting off tiger dicks it's ethically
sourced oh it just says who they found
one in the forest ethnically sourced
tiger dick they find a sleeping tiger i
do hear it though do you drink it and
helps fix your erections according to
the eastern philosophers what about
those gas station pills how do they work
do they work they work the answer is
they work they work i want to try them
and they say no headaches
do you guys know any chinese wizards my
mom does she has a lot of them can we
bring them on here for ask the expert
i'm a chinese sorcerer banana wizards do
they speak english
that's a tiger dick that's a ton of
peanuts that's a tiger penis wow it
looks like a tape worm dude it looks
like a shedded snake it looks like
something that's on my hard drive
so thanks guys
it's on your computer forever now is
there tiger penis wine are those the
testes i haven't seen them
all right so i think it's all dick i
think it's mostly dick
picture i didn't know this article was
going this direction so no
you kind of knew though i kind of did
yeah yeah i actually researched it there
yeah
yeah previous knowledge uh so yeah that
that's the story i mean you know it's
pretty ironic
he was trying to help his son and then
uh he gets bit by multiple sticks
[Laughter]
that's so crazy that is pretty good i
like a lot of animals but i never really
connected with reptiles and i don't
trust them
reptiles to me i
because i don't get them maybe i need to
spend more time to understand the way
that they react what's a good starter
reptile for you you think we don't have
a guy here with a mullet who can answer
that question that's the problem i feel
like fish are good
because they'll never really turn on you
unless you get a violent one like a
person that's the guy who got paranoid
weren't you a piranha plug but i got to
that point because i i i [ __ ] evolved
like from beginning baby steps you know
built your business yeah i was at the
fair and i got a goldfish from playing a
game and then i went up the levels from
guppies to whatever right and then
piranhas but then reptiles i don't know
how do you even start do you get an
iguana first get a turtle this is a
turtle you buy a plane
all right i'm listening okay so then you
sell it for a turtle okay
one turtle that's a lot of turtles you
want you started your business now get
some leftovers i have like 20 000
turtles and then just sell turtles yeah
i just solo and then you put them in a
bottle of wine
okay with a snake i like where you're
going with bart's eating turtle i know
he's cut one in half before too but one
time i never ate one they smell bad man
you have a turtle how is it it's good
you like it tastes like chicken really
you didn't have one that smelled like a
porta potty marinated it all was it
boiled yes it was fully fully marinated
was it boiled was how did they prepare
it i don't know how they prepared didn't
you tell us about [ __ ] you guys were
getting uber eats in china and then it
was like a turtle restaurant and all of
it was just different kinds of turtles
when i was in china they were passing
the phone they're like hey would you
like how we do chipotle i couldn't
scroll past any more turtles
like honey mustard turtle yeah honey
mustard turtle general so tell it all
[Laughter]
i mean was it the full turtle form like
it was that
it looked like bit like little turtles
in like bowls
oh turtle nuggets oh turtle
[Laughter]
so i mean how would they eat it though
do they just come over i didn't even get
it and they use the shell as the [ __ ]
bowl and then they rip it open and start
scooping it's usually when they serve it
like you it's the whole turtle so it's a
shell and then you literally just eat
the meat around it with the first time
scraping the first time you ate it how
did you feel did you feel whoa this is
crazy how [ __ ] yeah what was the texture
all right this is [ __ ] up i recall
me this is me okay which one did you eat
first the head or one of the arms farms
really was it a whole turtle yeah and
everyone got it like it's kind of like
you eating crab you just crack it open
pick up like a whole turtle wow
i went back to china with my dad in
junior high to visit some of my my
relatives
and when they were cooking it just
smelled weird and then they brought out
this plate of turtles and literally
smelled like someone set up a poor body
in the middle of the [ __ ] dining room
okay this is [ __ ] this is [ __ ] up fyi
a little warning if you're kids or
whatever before just turn your head or
whatever the [ __ ] this is a turtle pie
that's crazy dude that's funny that
doesn't even look organic dude that's
crazy ethically sourced you know what's
good about this though is that i don't
even see the turtle this is great i see
the turtle but this is the difference
between western and eastern cuisine okay
so western cuisine they blend everything
until you don't even know it's in there
anymore honestly though that looks
really is that an ice cream pie it's a
turtle cream turtle cream what the hell
is turtle cream yeah what the hell is
turtle cream it's a [ __ ] cake it says
fresh
cookie crust
rich pecans and caramel that looks
really good actually that's the turtle
and then they say turtle here on the
cream pie part so it's probably the tur
you come inside of a turtle and then you
put the rest of the turtle cream pie
yeah
it literally says turtle cream fire
so it's your [ __ ]
yeah or whoever or wherever you want to
fill it up it's up to you and the turtle
goes
that's the scientific noise
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you